the Joe Rogan experience this is light
heavyweight this so I wish I'd Swiss
John with dip out in back you guys do
your thing build though no no no no no
no I like what he's doing well no he's
defending it sure but here's here's the
thing he he's not stimulated by that
he's talking [ __ ] to the middleweight
champion in the world
he's busy talking [ __ ] is Israel's
talking [ __ ] to him - that's they're
having a lot of it's entertaining yeah
they're having a lot of fun but listen
ultimately I think it's good for
everybody
I think that's the that little feud
between Izzy and John John's first of
all it elevates Izzy because all these
people that didn't know who he was like
why is John generals talking [ __ ] oh
look at this mother for holy [ __ ] he's
good and then they watch his fights ago
this is why John Jones talking [ __ ]
because he's starched Robert Whittaker
basically the end of the first round the
fight was over Oh Robert it was [ __ ]
Ville do any social medias like Jamaa
where he's good everywhere how about
this great guy the best he's alive I'm a
great guy love him LAN honest is [ __ ]
you'd only bought a McLaren 720's when
he told me I was good I was so excited
for him I thought it was a car guys I
need be honest man I just bought it cuz
it looked like this anime character we
got the right car is it on the right
side when I know a car is awesome but
it's got a steering wheel on the wrong
side I'm like I know I saw this
incredible Porsche they had like this
1972 RS but I had the steering wheel on
the right hand side of my kid out of
here with that car on the wrong side
what's crazy is is he told me they
actually offered the fight to him
already do you know that jeez and he
went smart he's smart cuz he went owner
and you're not gonna canelo me before
you'd made with a Canela me you trying
to get me while I'm really young in the
game yeah no no we're doing two years
we're doing two years in Vegas yeah
that's a beautiful car man that's the
other day they sound good too it's a
spaceship inside mmm they're beautiful
man that's a beautiful car like great
[ __ ] he's special man I think he's
gonna be the next big superstar I really
do
he's got everything going for him talent
great personality he's fun I mean he
with as much skill as we've ever seen a
striker I mean he's Anderson Silva 2.0
he really is man his striking is out of
this [ __ ] world man but he has all
the skills Anderson had but he's amazing
on the mic yeah well you know and it was
like fun of it though it was almost like
well don't talk but he was so good it
didn't matter agree like Anderson was so
good it didn't matter if we didn't
understand we said everybody loved him
man because he was like who's the goat
at time also but also that the game is
different now it's so much of a specter
like entertainment yeah we're answering
still be Anderson but you're different
back then we were more appreciative of
those guys yeah I feel like I don't know
maybe the fanbase understood the sport
more because like GSP was huge not great
[ __ ] talker
Anderson Silva not a great [ __ ] like we
loved those guys Cain Velasquez terrible
talk never talk [ __ ] those were the big
boys yep yep GSP is a perfect example
nothing but nice always never talk [ __ ]
no no never
max Holloway minc'd max talked a little
[ __ ] but it's more playful ya know and
we'll see we'll see but stop and it
really doesn't talk [ __ ] unless you
shade it if you initiate it game match
oh it's a it's a Devastator and he's
good at so he likes people that him and
Jon Jones going back and forth it's kind
of [ __ ] it's good for both of them it's
great for Izzy
because if John is that concerned about
him everybody's got to realize like oh
this guy's for real and I always said I
wouldn't entertain it when people would
bring it up again is he too small it's
just a [ __ ] it's nothing it's like
Bigfoot we're never gonna see it get a
big difference there's a big is he's
[ __ ] big man when he walked up I've
never met him before when you like the
one damn dude you are not small no but
he's only about 200 or so pounds like
205 somewhere city was 203 I think yeah
he's in that range John's probably 235
right now right and John has two
brothers that are elite NFL athletes pro
long bro he comes from fantastic
genetics I mean he's just got super
athlete family they're just and he's
huge that one size difference is so big
could you see Izzy as a heavyweight I
don't know no I could know he would be
overblown it would be too hard for him
to deal with the really big guys they
swear it's gonna happen though is he
loves it he says go up to heavyweight
John Jones is he's gonna go up he's down
for what he's like I don't care man he
doesn't care well he's so good
technically I mean who knows man maybe
he's doing specific kinds of training
that keeps his body light and maybe if
he lifted weights we'd actually get
better the only thing I would worry
wearing me about that fight and I'd be
rooting hard for his he in that fight
with only thing that worries me is
John's wrestling oh yeah man you forget
how could remember takedown DC you know
he wanted to make a point first round so
if he wants to play that game you can
play it but John can do everything and
when he does one thing he does better
than anybody that's ever ever fought
utilized distance he utilizes distance
better than anybody he's the very best
at keeping you here and a lot of people
accused him of poking people in the eyes
there have been some incidents I don't
think he's doing it on purpose I think
and I agree with you he shouldn't do it
he should close his fist but what I'm
saying is the way his style is he keeps
you out here and then bang keeps you out
here bad to distance into the leg
oblique kick leg kick pops you with a
jab hits you with a knee keeps you here
keeps you here these are Santana's just
feeling out like a snake's tongue yeah
he's got space like this much space
where he could [ __ ] you up but you can't
hit him he's got this because he's he's
also he's so comfortable in World
Championship fights he said nothing but
World Championship that's all he knows
yes so when you're at the top of the
food chain with the bright lights main
event and you're like holy [ __ ] this is
the big one John's like this is a fight
I all his fight another day my office
another day that's how Tyson was when
Tyson was crushing people that's how
Anderson was when Anderson was crushing
people thrive in the light and they get
to this point where you're you have to
be so much better to beat them because
you're [ __ ] your pants going in
you're compromised and you're fighting a
guy who's at the peak he's in the zone
[Applause]